the black Shu also known as the
hellhound is just one of the many
demonic antagonists that edin Lorraine
Warren trapped in their Museum of cursed
objects over the years but the spirit
they captured as part of a long-standing
phenomena of wolf and lyan sightings
documented as far back as the second
millennium BCE first appearing in the
Epic of gilgames the black shuck would
take on many forms terrorizing Europe in
the form of a haunting spectral dog this
would continue until Ed and lra paid a
visit to the county of Essex in England
after being called upon in 1966 which we
know from the side of their black Shu
case File this is the file on the black
Shu the black Shu it was a case the
Warren investigated about a hell hound
that possessed a man in England he
terrorized the out of this town to
find out exactly what the black shu is
how it came to be common Legend in
folklore and pop culture and how edin
Lorraine managed to contain it in the
world of the controverse stick around to
the end of this
[Music]
video Welcome to Horror history where I
will keep diving into more and more
obscure Conjuring villains until people
stop watching in today's lesson we'll be
talking about the black Shu the
hellhound who would come to terrorize a
10-year-old Judy Warren and her
babysitter's Crush Bob palmary because
everything in this franchise has to be
named palmary for some reason the black
Shu would eventually Escape From The
moren's Basement along with many other
evil spirits after a teenage girl named
Daniela enabled the demon malus to let
all of the other Spirits out who let the
dogs out it's just one dog and Daniela
let it out Case Closed however prior to
this Escape in 1972 the black shuck had
a centuries long history of absolutely
terrorizing various parts of Europe
becoming a common staple of ancient
folklore that is still relevant today in
The Conjuring Universe the black shu is
stated to be a hellhound who possesses a
man turning him into a werewolf but in
real life black shock and werewolf seem
to be two separate urban legends so why
did Gary Doberman the director of
Annabelle com's home combine them it
seems like it was originally just going
to be the black Shu but producer James
Juan thought it would be cool to merge
Concepts I'm pitching this to James I'm
really excited about he's like oh that's
great he's like that's great what if
it's a werewolf and there is a
relatively famous case of the Warren
investigating a werewolf in England so
it ties into that Universe nicely so one
of the things I'll try to do in this
video is cover both mythologies and
explain how they come together to create
the creature that we see in Annabelle
comes home but to fully understand where
these stories originated from and how
this creature came to be contained by
edin lra in 1966 we'll need to take it
all the way back to ancient Greece
Babylon and
Rome in the interest of being thorough
let's start at the beginning with the
origins of werewolves the supernatural
transformation of a person into a wolf
is referred to as lycanthropy and the
first time that lycanthropy appears in
any historic text is in the story of
Gilgamesh that I mentioned earlier
Gilgamesh is a Sumerian warrior king who
rejects the advances of the Goddess
Ishtar afraid that she would transform
him into a wolf as she had to her
previous admirer talk about a toxic AXS
this is the first mention of a man
turned into a werewolf or dog likee
creature the lycanthropy is more of a
side note to the actual story and
notably it's used as sort of a
punishment or threat the term
lycanthropy originates from Lon a
legendary King from Greek mythology Lon
had the Greek God Zeus over to his place
as a guest you know just hanging out
with the boys and Len wanted to impress
Zeus by offering him a human sacrifice
carving up one of his own Sons but Zeus
did not appreciate this he wasn't really
into the whole filicide thing so he
decided he was going to punish Lyon by
transforming him into a wolf Zeus felt
that if it was his desire to rip apart
human flesh Lan should be cursed to live
the rest of his life as a wolf so where
Gilgamesh avoided Temptation in order to
avoid becoming a wolf Lon was unable to
do so and was forced to undergo the
transformation the wolf transformation
is a consequence but ALS Al a barometer
of each man's ability to control his
Primal instincts and going forward when
a person is possessed by a wolf or black
Shu they're tested with the temptation
to follow those instincts there are
numerous stories about humans turning
into wolves or being tormented by
wolf-like creatures throughout the
Middle Ages and Beyond but according to
the Warren's novel werewolf the first
officially documented case of
lycanthropy was in the year 1440 CE in
France I don't know what makes a case
official in their mind especially
considering most of their stories are
just made up I know I'm going to get
canceled again for saying that but look
at it like this regardless of whether or
not you believe in ghosts there are big
inconsistencies in the Warren stories
but that's not what this video is about
so let's get back to that case in France
the Warren site of publication known as
the book of werewolves written by Sabina
bearing gold as their source for early
accounts of lycanthropy now lycanthropy
has two definitions one refers to
someone who is deluded into thinking
they can transform into a wolf and the
other is the fictional condition where
you actually can physically transform
the book of werewolves seems to account
for lycanthropy by both definitions with
some accounts of serial killers who
claim to have turned into wolves but
some cases where the unreal behavior and
traits of wolves couldn't be accounted
for leading one to believe that the
person really did transform into a beast
but the case that the Warrens draw from
was about a man named Jil de Lael who
was a councilman for the French King
lvll was one of the most powerful
noblemen in France during the 15th
century but in 1440 he was brought to
trial for committing murder and other
horrible atrocities to Children it was
said that as he was high in his Tower a
fierce red glare would stream out and
the cries of those in pain were answered
by the sound of howling wolf at level's
trial two of his servants testified that
he had murdered hundreds hundreds of
children over the span of 80 years his
appearance at the trial was described as
unusual bearing gold describes
contraction of the muscles of the face
nervous quivering of the mouth spasmodic
twitching of the brow and above all the
Sinister expression in his eyes showing
that there was something frightful in
the man at intervals he ground his teeth
like a wild beast preparing for his prey
the feeling of becoming a wolf seemed to
be something that level enjoyed
providing an outlet for his murderous
desires but it seems as though bearing
Gold's re of level's story was more that
he had the delusion of being a wolf as
opposed to actually transforming into
one level was sentenced to death on
October 25th 1440 but at the end of the
century a new threat would wreck havoc
on towns throughout
Europe more stories of lycanthropy would
crop up throughout the 1400s and 1500s
but it was also around this time that a
new series of accounts began to terrify
European Travelers this would be the
legend of the black Shu According to
some lore it's believed that the black
Shu was a dog that originally died in a
fire and the dog's ghost was then said
to roam Europe terrorizing people along
the way according to the BBC in the
1500s there were over 500 reported
sightings of the black shuck it was said
to be a hellhound in fact the word shuck
is believed to be derived from the old
English word Sucka meaning devil she's
described as a ferocious Hound with
pitch black fur ranging anywhere in size
from a large dog to a small horse he's
sometimes recounted with big glowing red
eyes occasionally characterized with
just one huge red eye in the middle of
his forehead the spectral Beast is known
for stalking and intimidating his human
victim the BBC article states that in
1577 one documented case in blurg
reported that a snarling Beast broke
into a church rampaged through the
congregation and bit the necks of two
people who promptly dropped a dead but
the black Shu wouldn't always just
appear to harm or harass people some
black Shu sightings were instances of
the Hound being an unexpected protector
in littleport Cambridge Shire a local
girl reported that the shadowy canine
protected her from an attempted rape by
a local frier in the 1600s it was
commonly reported that the black shuck
would appear at Witch Trials the black
Shu would come to be known through
stories passed down and as is often the
case with lore like this became sort of
a moral lesson that parents would use to
teach their kids there are even early
reports of parents using the myth of the
black shu to keep their children from
going into certain rooms in their house
don't go in mommy and daddy's room
Beyond 900 p.m. otherwise the black Shar
will uh eat your face off so that's the
brief history of the werewolf and the
black Shar the werewolf got more love in
popular culture with early silent movies
reflecting a fascination with humans
taking on the appearance or behavior of
wolves La Cheney J J famously
popularized The Wolf Man now considered
a classic horror movie monster and
lycanthropy and Cinema remained popular
in movies in the ' 80s and90s and
continued to be a part of fantasy and
Supernatural worlds today regardless of
the cultural impact of these initial
early werewolf or black shock sightings
they still remained a thing that most
people didn't necessarily believe in but
in 1966 that was about to change for a
man named Bill Ramsay timeline wise the
black shuck file spotted in the Warren's
house and Annabelle comes home is
labeled in 1966 however the real
Warren's investigation of Bill ramsy
happened around 1989 according to their
novel werewolf this would be well after
the events of Annabelle comes home I
think it's obvious that it's supposed to
be the same case though and the movies
do take a lot of Liberties to
incorporate the Warren into these
supposedly true stories like for example
pretty much the entirety of The
Conjuring 2 but just to create
consistency with my other controverse
videos I'm going to stick with the movie
timeline according to their novel
werewolf Ed and lra claimed that they
were in London during this time period
because they were on vacation however
the notes found in the black Shu case
File from Annabelle comes home would
make it seem like they were called there
either way while getting ready for
dinner in their hotel the rain notices a
news story about a man named Bill Ramsay
from Essex who supposedly had several
attacks where he acted out like a wolf
in one instance warding off several
police officers lra stated I knew right
away what we were dealing with here it
was demonic possession but clearly the
poor man ramsy didn't understand this
however in addition to the Warren
suspecting demonic possession they also
had detailed notes on a strange fog it's
here that the black Shu proves itself to
potentially take on various forms while
it seems to have the ability to possess
humans and cause them to change like
Bill it can also take on a form of its
own and dissipate into the fog at least
according to the Warren's notes in
Annabelle comes home while it's not
clear where Bill Ramsay initially
encountered this entity in interviews in
the Warren's book he describes his first
experience of turning into a wolf at age
nine Bill had been playing by himself
when he was overcome with a cold chill
and a grotesque
smell now come to believe possession
started was when I was 9 years old
suddenly the temperature just just
dropped completely like midwinter
freezing cold there was a terrible stink
coming in the air like the S backed up
or something then I just literally flew
off the
handle I was mad at somebody Bill
describes being filled with a rage and
then getting the strength to rip a fence
post out of the ground when his father
ran outside to stop him Bill's strength
was too much and both parents had to run
inside for cover until the episode
passed Bill's father swears that when he
looked over his shoulder he saw a wolf
Bill didn't suffer another episode like
this until he was an adult in his early
20s he got married and had three kids at
some point in the early years of Bill's
marriage he started having horrific
nightmares that he was some kind of
monster and his wife was was afraid of
him as much as Bill may have tried to
keep another Wolf episode from happening
he couldn't suppress it one October
evening bill went out for drinks with
some co-workers and he started to feel
what he describes as a chill just like
he did as a kid and would later report
looking into the bathroom mirror and
seeing a wolf looking back at him Bill
tried to stifle this but ended up
attacking his co-workers in the car on
the way home with such aggression and
force that nobody could believe what
they were seeing his cooworker pulled
over and Bill ran into the woods later
the other men would chalk up the night's
events to build just trying to shake
them up several more incidents of
increasing intensity eventually got the
attention of the local media one night
he went to the ER with tremendous chest
pain where he claimed to be changing
into a monster he bit a nurse and fought
off several police officers throwing men
across the room he was eventually
sedated and from there sent to a mental
hospital which didn't last long and Bill
was not given an official diagnosis for
what was happening to him they ran all
the tests the brain scans and all this
kind of stuff but all the brain scan can
really tell you is not what's wrong with
you it's really what is it Bill
continued having episodes Each of which
left him feeling that he had brief ly
transformed into a wolf and exhibited
incredible amounts of strength but he
was struggling to find an answer and
that's when the Warren saw him on
television Lorraine called Bill who was
initially hesitant but she convinced him
that he'd been possessed by a demonic
Spirit as a child and needed an exorcism
so the ramies were flown into the United
States where the Warren worked with
Bishop Robert McKenna to purge the evil
spirit from Bill's body Ed Warren would
State I could sense Bill becoming very
troubled the moment we stepped into the
church the Demonic Spirit within him was
desperately trying to keep bill under
its control when father McKenna pressed
across into Bill's forehead it caused
him to thrash violently but after
several hours of struggle Bill described
feeling the demon leave his body as I
sat there I felt myself becoming
purified the poison that had been in my
body drained from me completely now the
exorcism seemed to work as the book ends
with Lorraine explaining that 2 years
had passed and that bill and his wife
had been living a happy and quiet life
on the south end on sea while Bill may
have been set free and the Demonic
Spirit driving his actions appeared to
be contained this would not be the last
time that the black shuck got loose but
the next victims would not have the
Paranormal couple's expertise to guide
them
[Music]
during their time in Essex the Warren
bought a book on the black shuck that
was scratched across the front as the
werewolf lashed out in a fit of rage
upon completing the exorcism the evil
spirit was captured inside this book
just as the Warren have been known to do
with other demons and spirits that they
overcome like baath Sheba in the music
box valik in the zoat Trope malus in the
Annabelle doll isa's demon in the Goblet
the fairy man in these gold coins the
vengeful bride in this wedding dress and
many others the black shuck would stay
safely locked away in this room where it
wouldn't bother another soul for the
next 6 years until one faithful night in
September of 1972 shortly before Judy's
birthday that year when Ed and lra had
to leave town their daughter Judy was
left in the care of her teenage
babysitter Mary Ellen but when Mary
Ellen's best friends Daniela learns that
she's babysitting for the Warrens who
made a name for themselves the previous
year when their investigation in Rhode
Island went mainstream she becomes
fascinated with the idea of coming over
and trying to get into the Warren's room
of haunted belongings later that
afternoon as Mary Ellen and and Judy are
baking the birthday cake Daniela shows
up for an unannounced visit coming in
through the back door she brings Judy a
pair of roller skates as a birthday
present and offers to watch the oven
while Mary Ellen takes Judy outside to
try them out with the house to herself
she finds the haunted artifact room
raids their office for the key please
don't judge me and proceeds to touch
everything including the book containing
the black shock when else did you touch
everything as danela explores the room
she discovers Annabelle in her case and
is immediately intrigued by her she
tries to use what she perceives as the
power of the room to speak to her dad
who had died in a car accident shortly
before but malus the powerful demon
residing in the Annabelle doll picks up
on her desperation and tips Annabelle
forward against the glass leading
Daniela to unlock the case and take her
out big mistake just as she does this
the cake that she'd promise to watch
starts burning setting off the smoke
alarm Daniela hurriedly puts Annabelle
back in the case but does not lock it
allowing malus to shove Annabelle
forward again opening the case and
setting the inhuman Spirit free to
interact with all of the other haunted
objects in the room including the black
shu the method by which the black Shu
was set free is significant to the
existing lore around the legend if
you'll recall during the previous
Millennium the story of the black Shu
became a cautionary tale used by parents
to scare their kids out of entering
certain rooms that they were prohibited
from the room of cursed objects is
clearly off limits with no less than
five locks and a warning sign but
Daniela Breaks the Rules and goes in
there anyway and like the early stories
of characters who failed to restrain
themselves from their instincts there
would be consequences for breaking the
rules Judy is the first one to be
tormented by the now free roaming demons
in the house she screams out for help
from upstairs as Mary Ellen calms her
down Daniela once again uses this time
to explore the house trying to learn as
much as she can about the cases that the
Warren have studied Mary Ellen and Judy
later find her in the office looking
into the case file on the black shuck
and she already seems to know a lot
about it she finds a photo of a goat
with its throat ripped out diagrams of
people who had been attacks and notes as
the Warren had clearly initially been
trying to figure out what could be
causing these attacks one photograph
shows the shuck standing upright a
result of the combination of the initial
black shuck Legend with that of a
werewolf there's also a veterinarian
chart which could be a copy of the
medical record of the dog that died in
the fire that I mentioned earlier and
they mentioned St Mary's Church this is
the same church that the shuck allegedly
attacked and killed two people at in
bleb the girls continue looking at the
Case Files until Daniela pushes things
too far turning on a projector that
plays an exorcism performed by Ed Warren
Mary Ellen shuts that off and insists
that they go play a board game instead
but they're interrupted by a ring of the
doorbell from Bob palmary Mar Ellen's
Crush who lives across the street
apparently testing the water to see if
Mary Ellen will let him join her oh Bob
they don't really want me having boys
over so he moves to plan B returning
shortly thereafter with a guitar to
serenate her on the front lawn Bob's got
balls this apparently works and Mar
Ellen races downstairs to come outside
and greet him but she's too late I guess
the black shuck was not as impressed
with Bob's clunky guitar playing as Mar
Ellen was and decided to attack him
should have gone with Baja man Bob
that's just a joke they did not exist
back then he's able to hear the hellish
creature breathing in the bushes and
senses something is wrong just in time
to get away and hide in a chicken ceop
in the backyard where he spends the
duration of the night after at first I
thought it was kind of unfair that Bob
is essentially being hunted because of
daniela's transgression but considering
that there are already several other
demons terrorizing danela it would make
sense that the shuck would try to go
after B many of the characters involved
in the initial lycanthropy stories that
I discussed in mythology such as
gilgames and Lon were tested to see if
they could hold back their Primal
instincts with the werewolf
transformation serving as an indicator
if they failed to do so in this case
Bob's Primal instinct is trying to get
with Mari Ellen but there's a clear
boundary that has been set the Warren
don't want Mar Ellen having boys over on
a subtextual level the black shock
represents a test of Bob's restraints to
reveal what kind of person he actually
is he seems respectful when he's told
that he can't come in but ultimately
tries to find kind of a loophole by
Serena her from outside I personally
think this is fine because it's not like
Mar Ellen is going to get in trouble for
having an admirer who she didn't let in
but either way this midnight mut is
going to put the Bob's got Ball's
nickname to the test as Bob hides in the
chicken CE the black shuck lurks outside
slaughtering any chickens wandering
around outside of it and leaving Bob
petrified in his hiding
[Music]
place mean meanwhile the Demons Inside
the house proceed to terrorize Daniela
Judy and mariellen causing marielen to
suffer an asthma attack she does have an
inhaler but it's outside in her car so
Judy Rises to the occasion to retrieve
it before anyone can stop her the house
is uncharacteristically shrouded in
thick fog a call back to the details
from edin L's research on the black
shuck having an eerie effect on the
weather in Mar Ellen's car Judy realizes
that she's being circled by a predatory
entity it shatters one of the windows
climbs onto the roof and slashes through
the steel causing Judy to run for it as
it gains on her Bob comes around the
corner and uses his guitar as a weapon
smashing it across the face of the black
Shu which destroys the guitar but the
black Shu just dissipates back into fog
and then reforms further down the
driveway but Bob does manage to save
Judy who locks them both out of the
house when the creature barges up
against the
door the fact that Bob chose to use his
guitar the thing that he was hoping
might convince Mary Ellen to let him
come inside might be what demonstrates
that Bob's care for her and Judy is real
or you know maybe the black shuck didn't
like his guitar playing and just decided
to do his best animal house
[Music]
reenactment sorry but the black shuck is
still not quite done with him and chases
him presumably back to the chicken coop
inside the house Judy is able to give
Mary Ellen her inhaler and eventually
the three girls manage to lock malus and
the Annabel doll back into their case
which sends all of the other Demons back
into the possessions that they possess
including the black shock Bob does at
this point come into the house but this
time he takes on the role of the
protector of marelen Daniela and Judy
until the Warren get home the next
morning while Bob did make it into the
house the black shuck had really put him
through a test and he came out on the
other side revealing himself to be a
good person Bob further proves this by
joining Mary Ellen and Daniela in
attending Judy's birthday and further
encouraging other kids to come and
that's the last anyone sees or hears
from the black shuck for now but could
we see another curious guest set this
Commonwealth K9 free once again uh
probably not but I do have this idea
that I've talked about on my channel
before I think it would be really cool
to one day have a contemporary Conjuring
movie and the perfect opportunity to do
it would be this news story that
happened in 2020 where it was reported
that the annabal doll escaped from the
Warren's occult museum at the time it
was closed and being looked over by
Judy's husband Tony spara I think
there's an interesting story there with
Tony and Judy being in charge for the
first time with Lorraine having passed
away the year before and having to rise
to the occasion facing one of the most
powerful demons in Conjuring lore all in
the shadow of the hysteria that was the
year 2020 if they ever did something
like this it stands for reason that
malus could set free the other spirits
in the room again and I would personally
like to see them focus on the other evil
entities instead of the three that were
already featured in Annabelle comes home
but it would be cool if the black shuck
made a quick Easter egg appearance and
by the way I'm aware that the rumor of
Annabelle's Escape was just a
mistranslation from a Chinese website
and Tony cleared things up pretty
quickly after that but again I don't
think that means that they can't make
that movie especially considering that
most of this franchise is just based on
exaggerated and sometimes madeup stories
as I alluded to there are a lot of
conjuring antagonists whose stories
deserve a closer look so check out that
playlist on the left for my deep Dives
on the franchise's most horrifying
villain and remember to subscribe to C's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell and select all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both
survive